You know I think we all know something special
happened yesterday on Brotherhood 2.0, but
I don’t, I don’t think we have to talk
about it; I don’t think we have to go into
details about how it felt, or how wonderful
it was. Uh, it’s like the last night of
camp, you know? You experience it, and you
just know, because it’s in here.
Good morning, Hank. (Wii-mote beeps) Wow it
makes noise! It’s Tuesday, January 30th,
hold on one second, I just, I just have to,
I just have to play my new Wiiiiiiiii!
Yes! Yes!
It occurs to me now that playing the Wii is
one of those things that feels a lot cooler
than it looks.
Something from the comments: Commenter “anonymous”,
wait, isn’t that Ze Frank’s thing? Doesn’t
he say “S-something from the comments”?
We gotta think of something else; we gotta
have like a Voices from the Comments! “Anonymous”
says, "Hank, you keep raising the bar. I feel
kinda bad for John and his unenviable position
of following your postings." YOU feel kinda
bad for John?! Jesus, anonymous, try being
John! Ugh, what am I gonna do today? I got
some in your pants jokes, anyone wanna hear
some in your pants jokes?
But Hank, I’d like to discuss a serious
issue, which is the issue of Everyone Poops.
Hank, the question I have for you and our
viewership is this: Which is funnier, Everyone
Poops in My Pants, or Everyone Poops in Your
Pants?
Brotherhood 2.0 project: Once we decide whether
Everyone Poops in Your Pants, or Everyone
Poops in My Pants is funnier, I’m going
to write an entire picture book called one
of those two titles, which I will then read
on the air. Maybe, if we get lucky, the Yeti
will do some drawings.
In other news, I seem to have accidentally
Cc-ed you on an e-mail. STUPID STUPID! This
means that I have to do a punishment. Hank,
be kind to me. Remember, we’re brothers.
I’ll see you tomorrow.